i think it's a way to liberate yourself
from anxiety
it's sort of a way to grow up that you
know if you're worrying about
your car payments or how you need
breast enlargement or any of these
things
then i'm not sure you are fully grounded
in the big picture and psychedelics give
you the big
picture i mean they they show you
exactly where
in the cosmic scheme you fit which
doesn't mean that they diminish you
it's not a oh goodness i'm a mere speck
in the cosmos
perception it isn't that it's it
shows you precisely where you fit
and that relieves anxiety
and as things proceed toward the
concrete sense
it's going to get crazier we have an
immense
capacity for craziness i mean as an
example
the soviet union the great menace
this historical nightmare yada yada yada
it's gone it doesn't exist anymore
it's nowhere to be seen and
most people's attitude is yeah so what
else is new
so this immense event happened it only
happened
five or six years ago and we're already
on to yeah
so what some something
but as time speeds up
change is going to come faster and
faster we will have our
para perestroika and you know all the
smugness about those silly marxists and
how they couldn't get it together
this society is fraught with
contradictions
like nothing marxism ever dreamed of and
when
the chickens come home to roost in this
scene
you may be sure the [ __ ] will hit the
fan am i
stringing my metaphors here
and the the hardest thing to do is to
preach
catastrophic transformative change
in a place like esselm i mean i've been
coming to westland since
1975 every time you come here
the staff the people i know who live
here they take me aside and say
oh it's just it's just getting wilder
and wilder and
the factions are rising we're having big
changes there's been a lot of big
change recently and you know well hell
you know they must have microscopes i
don't have
because as far as i can see they haven't
tightened the bolt or turned the screw
around here since 1980 uh
and and that and nestle i'm not knocking
eslin
uh esalen though is a microcosm of our
society
we say change what change you know i
have to decide whether
i'll vacation in hawaii or southampton
this year
that's changed go to bosnia
go to rwanda go to bangladesh go to
bangkok calcutta the sense or even you
know moscow these
the sense of chaos is palpable
it's palpable and you i don't mean you
have to go to a crisis
scene like rwanda just fly into
bangkok on a normal business day
and you will suddenly understand
something that you can't understand by
reading newspapers in this country
you'll understand what population bomb
third world explosion high
technology what all these terms mean
because those folks are eating it
right and left and here
in the quiet ivory towers of the
managerial
societies where the grand metaphors are
handed down
to everybody not much seems to be
happening
it'll come here last i'm sure
i'm sure i mean even europe is in
turmoil compared to the united states
by a long shot i mean europeans are not
so
so weirdly childish or something like
that film last night
you know they had problems they dealt
with them
it didn't require exegesis
of second daniel or
as it would here they just solved their
social problems
by lightening up a little and society
didn't fall apart
this is a bastion of recidivism
and conservatism and let's do it the old
way-ism
and it's a disgrace you know we're
losing money we're losing time
and we're losing a sense of
participation in the global adventure
but it doesn't matter because the
changes that are coming
can overwhelm any political scheme i
mean eventually the planet itself
will weigh in and you know this is not
something that can be finessed by
politicians
in collusion with the new york times
it's bigger
than that if you love all those things
the unpredictable the mysterious the
unexpected
you love what is happening and if you
hate those things
you absolutely hate what is happening
you say that the world is getting worse
and worse it's getting
terrible agony hunger hysteria
these things are spreading that's right
but not faster than
integration information managerial
skills strategies for salvation
and new technologies and social
interventions
it's all of a piece but my faith
is novelty will win it is
winning or we wouldn't be here talking
like this
novelty is winning and it will win and
therefore
you know sit back and
enjoy the show
[Music]
you